well I'm looking for to recovering my
tendon getting it back and getting back
in the groove you think there'll be a
chance that you come back another season
to kind of redeem yourself well I would
do that in a beat I could come back in a
second if they I was that done that has
happened before in the past oh really
and it would be up to her what do you
think about the chance Amber Riley and
Derek once again I did something today
that I had not done before I watched
Bruno watch them not cannot the whole
dance but I watched him counting with
his pen and I looked at her feet man she
is dead on I have to say that that's not
the whole point but that is an amazing
choreographer and amber especially with
an injury in both knees just was
fantastic she brings it my goal I
remember like week one you said you know
do you want to beat your sis and I was
like hey is long as I can just match her
then she can't really say she was
abetted on so like we're even now it was
amazing I mean just take the final three
you never thought that was the whole
lineup from the beginning on Good
Morning America it's like you would
think for sure Elizabeth Nicole I mean
he has so many other options and we were
not one of them we did not fit in the
Final Four so the fact that we came in
third is pretty amazing I have to ask
Thanksgiving is right around the corner
so what do you guys most thankful for I
am probably most thankful for my family
and most thankful for having such an
awesome dance partner
is this one going to go next to the Emmy
now I I don't know yeah why not it's a
beautiful thing you have so many disco
balls it should be a mirror room now I'm
gonna play down and then they'll thing
they turn bringing it so it's like an
actual you know what has the look on
your face when you heard that you won
was beyond priceless but all of us were
like it's gonna be amber it's gonna be
amber were you really that surprised it
was a bigger piece you just never know
you know in this competition and for me
I just never really thought about I'm
not a competitive person by nature and I
just never really thought about winning
until maybe the last two weeks but I was
just like you know what I had needles in
my knees and I'm going through all this
obviously I want this more than I'm
willing to it me so you know I I didn't
know I honestly just didn't know who was
gonna win it could have been anybody my
family's been supportive but I have to
say it's been Derrick you know my
partner he's the person that I've been
with more than than anybody and you know
you kind of have to have that good
partnership all the way to make it all
the way to the end everyone I feel like
has had a really great partner but he
was like tailor-made for me I feel like
what's next oh man sleep and ice
Leoben ice ice and those legs so guys as
it was the finale how was it being able
to get back together and dance ya know
he's amazing it was so good to be back
you know we always feel like we were
kind of cut showed a little bit because
I wanted him to do more and we felt like
we've had more to give America so when
we came back together it was nice to be
reunited with Mark and Christina and do
the Dan
then it was great fun I'm so happy it's
over but it's been like the experience
is exactly what I wanted out of it which
was for one I want I wanted to make it
all the way to the end because I wanted
to be able to fulfill every single week
to be able to get out here and do what I
love doing but I mean I grew up
entertaining and and I'm gonna continue
doing it and we got a chance to do this
from Corinna night we pull out some
numbers I'm excited about it and and I
really really got an incredible
personality how are you feeling give me
an update
I'm doing well the medication seems to
be working for my other like the cancer
and I'll know in two weeks what the net
latest brain scan looks like that's the
only way they can tell with this I
joined have worked with him again he's a
dolly positive he's kind he supported
he's strict and he absolutely demands
that I don't make dumb mistakes wish I
make over and over
I really do I've been social dancing for
50 years incorrectly like this for
crimped it's a Jewish word that means
behind a shriveled you know what I mean
a no-no you've got to anyway it's been
very interesting to learn a new form of
dance at my age she took on this
challenge with me and she never once
griped about her she never backed away
from any problems she just kept pushing
me and pushing me and we achieved
something that nobody saw us doing you
know I didn't see us doing it I could
not be more proud of anybody than this
little lady right here he hasn't told
anybody but he actually emailed my dad
I brought my phone which means next in
America he rubbed my phone and email my
dad to say what a wonderful girly for it
was and thank you for letting him dance
with you daughter and and then my dad
emailed by saying oh but I showed you
you don't know me he's very proud that
he's my American
we felt so great and it was really a
great night to be dancing without the
stakes of being judged or voted for you
know just to dance for the pure joy of
it what's really great now I mean when
you when you come here and then you see
all the emotion behind the scenes are
you guys you guys are really this close
on this emotional and let's see the ends
how is it the stakes are high and this
show I mean you have to work so hard
you cannot just get by so there's no
take to you know so we're all in it
together we're at in the rehearsal space
together we're just going through it
together it's it's intense it was just a
good experience because I feel like
during this time you know I just had a
baby and I'm trying to be a mother and
growing into myself as a woman so I feel
like this was the perfect time to you
know be on Dancing with the Stars
because you have to be elegant and be
like this lady that I never thought I
could be and I think I you know pulled
it off and it's just taught me new
things about myself